وهو ينضم إلينا الآن على الهواء مباشرة دكتور سانجاي جوبتا ،
حسنًا صباح الخير ،
لديك عدد من النصائح مثل لا
أعرف أهم أربعة أشياء يمكننا القيام
بها في هذا الخريف الجديد
للبقاء آمنين والحفاظ على
أمان أحبائنا و  كيف يختلف الأمر عن العام الماضي ،
نعم ، أعني أنني أمضيت بعض الوقت فقط
أتحدث إلى الخبراء الذين تعرفهم أشخاصًا
هم أطباء الأمراض المعدية
وعلماء الفيروسات الذين شاركوا في
صناعة اللقاحات ومن المثير للاهتمام
سماع وجهات نظرهم
لأنهم يعرفون وباءً كل شخص  نوع من
التعامل مع نفس المشكلات التي يواجهها الأطفال في
المنزل الذين يحاولون الوصول إلى العمل أثناء التخطيط
لحفلات الزفاف مهما كان الأمر ،
فإليك قائمة بالأشياء التي ظهرت من هذا النوع
وأحاول شرح ذلك جيدًا
في المقالة التي تقدم الاستشهادات والأدلة
لكل هذه الأشياء  التطعيم على
رأس القائمة ، ليس من المستغرب أن يكون
هناك الكثير من الأشخاص الذين ما زالوا لم
يتلقوا
اللقاح بالكامل ، فاللقاح ليس
حكاية خرافية تنتهي بهذا الوباء
ولكن الجميع أكدوا  من المهم جدًا
منع المواقف التي كنت
تصفها للتو في المستشفيات أقنعة روبن وعلى
وجه التحديد النوع المناسب من الأقنعة
لا ترمي تلك الأقنعة ، فنحن بحاجة إليها ،
لا يزال بإمكان 95 n95 إخفاء أفضل الأقنعة
للتحقق من التهوية ، وهذا أمر
مهم حقًا لا يفعله الأشخاص  تحدث عن هذا
بما فيه الكفاية في منزلك في المباني
التي قد تزورها ، وهناك جميع
أنواع المعلومات حول كيفية القيام بذلك
اختبار
شيء آخر لا نتحدث عنه
كثيرًا ولكن هناك اختبارات مستضد اختبارات سريعة
يمكنك إجراؤها بنفسك
home robin أجرينا هذه المحادثة في العام الماضي ،
فأنت تعلم فكرة أنه يمكنك
اختبار نفسك يوميًا
والإجابة على السؤال الذي
تحاول الإجابة عليه حقًا وهو هل أنت مُعدٍ في
ذلك اليوم ثم أخيرًا قضيت الكثير
من الوقت في الحديث  حول كيفية إعادة تقييم
روبن للمخاطر ، كنت أقوم ببعض
تناول الطعام في الأماكن المغلقة في وقت سابق من هذا الصيف كما كان العديد
من الخبراء الذين تحدثنا إليهم مع العديد من الأشخاص
الذين يطلبون ذلك مرة أخرى وهم يفكرون في
هذا على أنه نوع من الطقس  روبن أن
هذه العقلية التي سمعتها مرارًا
وتكرارًا تتغير تمامًا مثل الطقس ،
فقد تكون هناك أوقات تحتاج فيها إلى سحب
مظلة وهناك أوقات لا
تذهب فيها إلى أماكن
معينة وكيف تحافظ عليها كيف تتبع
من ذلك في حياتك الخاصة